- Hello, welcome to our
daily homeroom livestream
for those of y'all who are new to this.
This is a live stream that
we're doing every day as the name implies,
to keep us connected and answer questions
and figure out ways to
support each other during
these times of school closures.
It's also a forum for you to ask me
and our guests questions,
and we're gonna have a really
interesting guest today.
I will remind folks Khan Academy
we are not for profit with a
mission of providing a free
world-class education for anyone anywhere,
and we're able to do the work we do
because of donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I wanna give a special thanks
to several corporations
that have stepped up in the last few weeks
as we see it our Costco
hire, do the COVID crisis.
We've seen our traffic
be almost three acts
of what it typically is.
A special thanks to bank of America,
Google.org, Fastly, Novartis and AT&T.
So with that, I wanna get
right into the conversation,
I have a really great guest today
who's going to be able to
address a lot of concerns
that I think are out there.
Lorraine Hastings is the vice president
with the College Board.
For those of you all who are not familiar
with the College Board, the College Board
is a not for profit.
We are partnered with the College Board.
But the College Board also offers the SAT
and Lorraine specializes in relations
with college counselors, and
is an expert on all things
that are going on in the SAT right now.
I know there's a lot of questions.
And so first of all, Lorraine, welcome.
Thank you for being here.
I hope everything is good with your family
and this time of social distancing.
Maybe a good place to start is you know,
what's the lay of the land for those of us
who haven't been fully keeping
track of what's going on
with the SAT with regards to COVID?
- Hi, Sal, thanks again for
the invitation to join today.
I hope you and your
family are well as well
as your colleagues.
The work you do at Khan Academy
could not be more important
as it is today,
as we all learn to navigate
this difficult time.
As the College Board responds
to the impact of Coronavirus.
Our top priorities are the
health and safety of students
and educators.
In face of school closures,
we're adapting to give
students opportunities
to still show their strengths
and continue on the path to college.
We're working hard to make
the SAT available in school
and out of school
as soon as the public
health situation allows.
Right now public health
officials have made it clear
that it is not safe to
gather students in one place.
Many states have closed school
for the rest of the school year,
and globally there is
widespread school closures
across 192 countries.
Last week, we announced
that we will not be able
to administer the SAT as
planned on June sixth.
If it's safe from a
public health standpoint,
we will provide weekend SAT
administration's every month
beginning in August through
the end of the calendar year.
This includes a new
administration in September,
and the previously scheduled
tests on August 29th,
October the third, November the seventh
and December the fifth.
In the unlikely and I say
unlikely event that schools
do not reopen this fall,
we will provide a
digital SAT for home use.
We of course would ensure
that at home SAT testing
is simple, secure, fair
and accessible to all
and most importantly,
valid for use in college admissions.
I know that I've shared a few changes,
but Sal, even though it seems
as if everything is changing,
there is one thing that's not changing,
and that's the official
student practice available
for free anytime,
through our partnership with
you all at Khan Academy.
- No, and this is super useful.
And so just to make sure that I understand
what the College Board's
position on this is,
is as soon as we're through
this stay at home order,
y'all are going to
essentially offer the SAT
on the regular schedule thereafter
and offer a few more.
Hopefully you can kind of
view these as maybe makeup.
So it's a monthly time period.
And so is your view that
this will be sufficient
for guidance counselors out there advising
students or for students,
parents, teachers?
How do you think this is gonna
affect the admissions process?
Do you think this will
be students will have
an opportunity to get in there
and show that they're
college ready on the SAT?
- Yes, as you mentioned, Sal,
you're absolutely correct.
Once we get back hopefully
to the new normal in August,
we're gonna add a new
testing date in September
which we have not had a
September admin before.
And by providing monthly
testing beginning in August,
we are confident that all
students who want an opportunity
to take an SAT exam will
have the opportunity
to do so throughout the fall,
take it more than once if they so desire.
So this once again,
as counselors continue
to work with students,
they will be able to advise them,
what's the best administration's
they feel students should be able to take.
- And I wanna encourage
everyone listening.
Feel free to put your questions on YouTube
and Facebook we have team
members who are looking
at the questions and we're
gonna be able to surface them
up for Lorraine or for myself
if they're appropriate.
So there's a lot of
questions and I you know,
I definitely wanna underline
something you said.
You said in the unlikely event that
we are still in this crisis in the fall,
then y'all are going to try
to do a digital version of the SAT
similar to what y'all are doing for the AP
and in a few weeks.
So I wanna underline that's
in the unlikely event
because we are getting questions around
what is that going to look like?
How are you going to prevent cheating?
Et cetera, et cetera.
But that I would guess
you're still figuring out
if you even have to go there.
- Yes, and, you know,
a very unlikely event that
we have to do an at-home test.
Test security is, of course,
one of our highest priorities.
And we're gonna design
a solution that meets
our rigorous standards, we
will have a comprehensive,
strict set of protocols
in place to prevent
and detect cheating.
And of course, we can't share everything
we're gonna do because we need
to maximize the effectiveness
of the things that we will be employing
to make sure that the test is secure.
- And I have a question from Facebook,
Chris Lee asked what about
the SAT subject tests?
- So we had to cancel the subject tests
that were administered that were supposed
to be administered in June.
Those are some of the
foreign language ones.
And those will be administered
later on in the year
and the normal schedule of subject tests
in the fall will continue.
Those will be options for
students and the fall as normal.
- And a question from
Facebook, Julian Michael says,
"Do you foresee a move to
digital testing regardless
"of when schools open?"
And I guess related, you know,
in certain standardized tests,
not that the College
Board offers but you know,
I remember when I took the G math,
you know, many years ago it
was it was digital back then.
Is this something that y'all
are thinking about generally,
or maybe catalyzed by COVID.
- So, of course, we're going to once again
I want to continue to stress,
Sal, what you said earlier,
unlikely event, we'll do this.
If depending on what happens in the fall,
we're aware that some places
in the country in the world
may open and others may not.
So we are trying to prepare
to address multiple different
scenarios whether it's a blended option,
we plan on paper and pencil
continuing in the future.
The at-home is only in the unlikely
event that we are not able to
administer paper and pencil.
- Yeah, and I'll just triply
underline what you said
because we're getting a lot of questions.
But the questions are a good indicator
of how you know what people kind of latch
onto they are like digital SAT?
The SAT's changing?
What you're saying this
is in the very, you know,
that's a reality where COVID and it looks,
you know, hopefully,
you know, knock on wood
we have we have a handle on it now,
or it's at least hopefully peaked.
But this is in the unlikely scenario
that we're still in this full
social distancing scenario,
August, September, October,
which hopefully is unlikely
so people should not index on it too much.
- That is correct.
We're going to continue to monitor
the situation around the Coronavirus
and we're going to USE whatever we learn
to inform whatever our
approach will be in the future.
- Yeah, and I had this
question from Facebook,
Makai Kiefer, and this is
a question that I guess
is relevant even before this.
You hear things about schools
being testing optional.
Many colleges and universities have stated
that they will not require
SAT exams for students
applying next year.
Do you know how they
will handle the situation
and how students without SAT scores
compare to those with scores?
And how would you advise
students whether to SAT or not,
if and when it becomes available?
I'd love to your thoughts.
And I have some thoughts there too.
I'm happy to share.
- Sure, so once again,
many colleges are making decisions whether
or not they're going to be
test optional in the fall.
Colleges are members of the College Board,
and we work with them,
encourage them to be flexible
and different scenarios
different situations.
As always, flexibility
in the admissions process
is very important for students
and colleges have committed
to take that into account.
They are aware of the circumstances
and the public health crisis.
And they will use that when
they're considering test scores,
grades, extracurricular activities.
They are truly emphasizing flexibility
and that's what we keep hearing from them.
The best advice for students
is always to reach out
to the colleges that they're interested in
and have a conversation with them.
Some colleges may not require the SAT.
But we're still encouraging
students to take the SAT,
if possible, to help show their skills.
Because once again,
it's a part of many pieces that
go into the college admissions process.
And the stronger your portfolio
can be for college admissions,
the better your chance
and likelihood of being accepted
at the college that you want to go to.
- Yeah, and I'm underlining
some very important things
you're saying because what
I've been telling friends
and family members and even some questions
on this live stream when
I've had high school juniors
ask me what to do I said exactly that.
It's not that the SAT is just
a thing that you have to do
because it's some ritual that
goes on goes on in society.
Colleges are getting so many applications
they're trying to determine
who's college ready,
who's not, who's going
to be able to contribute
to the community in enriching ways.
And so there's a lot of things
they're going to look at
to make those decisions.
And so of course,
your grades matter, your
extracurricular activities matter,
your essays matter.
But the SAT and things
like it are valuable
because it gives a read a
signal that in conjunction
with all of these other things
do correlate based on you know,
the admissions officers
I've talked to with success in college.
And so I would say if you are able to,
and it's great that you're offering
these extra testing dates to take it,
because that's going to
give you one more signal
one more data points to colleges.
At the same time, I would not stress.
In theory, you should
never stress about it,
you should just do your best
and then see what choices you have.
But I think if you have
the opportunity to do it,
but this is shouldn't be
something that causes stress
because this year more than any year,
people are definitely very understanding
about being flexible about things.
But yeah, that was my two cents.
- And, Sal, I always like to
remind students that colleges
need students to survive.
That's what they're there for.
So they are going to be flexible.
They're going to work with students,
and they're going to do
what's in the best interest of students.
- Yeah, and from YouTube,
this is a good question
and act your future
asks "Will juniors who
missed the SAT in April,
"have the test administered
for free at their school
"during a weekday
"or will they have to take it
on one of those weekend days?"
And I think this is hitting a point
that a lot of school districts
or systems will administer
the test for free
during the week day.
Then the weekends are normally
something that the
families have to pay for.
So how are y'all navigating that?
- So we will also in addition
to this typical school day
schedule that we have in the fall,
which is around October,
we are giving schools the opportunity
for an additional date
for testing in the fall.
So schools will have also
an additional opportunity
to test students and
the states and districts
that do it for free for students,
they will have that
opportunity to do it this fall.
So they will be hearing
more from their schools
and districts and even states
about what that testing
schedule will look like.
- And from YouTube,
this Maciel Govender asked "what about
"the SAT for foreigners?"
Are they also wanna have access
to everything you're
talking about in the US?
- So once again,
should it be safe to do so
from an inner from a public
health standpoint, we're
going to provide multiple SAT
administration's also for
international students.
This includes the new
administration in September,
as well as the previously
scheduled test for August,
October and December.
This fall, we actually already announced
that we were going to add
an additional opportunity
for international students in August.
That was pre Coronavirus.
And since then we have
also added in September.
So once again,
that's there and then we
are seriously also exploring
the possibility of even
providing an additional
international administration
day in the fall.
In addition to the two that
we have already announced,
so absolutely.
Our international students
are very important to us.
- And from Facebook,
we have two questions,
one from Tracy McFadden
and one from Katie Budinger
and these are essentially
the same question,
which is, "how fast or
will the will the scores
"be from the fall testing
administration's?"
And I guess the obvious
question, you know,
a lot of students would
have taken it this spring
and then seeing their scores and said,
is this a good score for me
to use for my applications?
So how are y'all thinking about that?
- So we absolutely want
to make sure that students
have their scores and
time to make decisions
to register for an additional testing
if that's what they need.
So we will be working
quickly to make sure students
have this their scores.
- And one question from Facebook
zombie SMA says,
"why can't the SAT be
administered in July?"
I think I know the answer,
but I'd love your thoughts, Lorraine.
- Well, once again,
we continue to look at what
the health situation is.
Many of our test centers
are actually schools,
high schools, college campuses.
And you know,
we still are not confident.
We don't know
if things are going to
be available in July,
and we thought, you know,
August gives us a good safe distance.
Hopefully we will be past this crisis.
And the last thing we want
to do is to have students
register for another test
that we end up having
to reschedule or cancel.
So we're trying to just
go with the safe option.
And following once again,
we continue to follow what's going on.
We monitor activities in
the state across the world,
because we want to make
sure it is absolutely safe
and secure for students to test.
- And from Facebook,
Gabriela Saslogi asks,
"Is one date in August and September
"going to be enough given
"all the backlog of people
wanting to take the test?"
So that kind of goes to a
capacity issue, you know,
sometimes you can't find your date
because maybe it fills up at
your local testing centers.
Are y'all going to be
addressing that as well?
- Yes so two things with that, Sal.
For each administration,
we're preparing to significantly
expand our capacity
for students to take the test
as soon as schools reopen.
We are calling on our
member schools and colleges
as well as local communities
to open their doors
and provide additional
test center capacity.
So every student who wants to test
will also be able to test.
In addition to that,
students who registered for June
and also those in the class of 2021,
who do not have SAT scores
will also have early
access to registration.
And we're going to get back to students
about what this actually means
and what they need to do.
But our top priority will be
make to make sure that students
in the class of 2021, which
are the rising seniors,
who don't have an SAT scores,
get the seat that they need
so that they won't have to worry
about not being able to
find someplace to test.
- Yep and I think that's
once again worth emphasizing
because there's other
questions we're getting,
like from Facebook,
Ilana Miller, you know,
suggesting multiple testing dates
and multiple testing even
more than what you're already
offering is hard because
you have to create new tests
and test securities.
But to your point,
people shouldn't be concerned
about capacity issues
because that's in place.
So we have a question.
Let's see actually just disappeared.
But I thought it was
an interesting question
around fee waivers.
You know, there's a lot of
families going through economic
hardship right now who
might have had, you know,
who might not have qualified
for a few waivers a month ago,
but now, things have changed.
How are y'all looking at that process?
- So fee waivers.
We have fee waivers for
students who need fee waivers.
Students should contact their
school, their counselor.
We actually, since we know
schools are closed right now.
So there's not the paper
waiver that students
can get out counselors will have access
to digital Fee Waiver codes
that students will be used to register
and get their test fees waived
as long as they meet the
requirements for fee waivers.
- Yeah and from YouTube
Ashley Pascale asks,
"If a test is rescheduled,
"will students be able to apply
the payment to a new date?"
- Yeah, so the June
tests that was canceled,
students will be able to reapply
that to a fall registration
when registration opens up in May.
- Okay, and there's a lot of.
- If a student, yes.
Go ahead, Sal.
- No, and related to that,
I know this gets into a
little bit of logistics of it.
People asking questions about oh,
my March date got canceled
and they're thinking
about things like refunds,
and, you know, I will go to
your defense where I think
everyone is trying to
process everything right now.
But what assurances can you give families
that no you're gonna be able
to get to it and everything
will work worked out fairly?
- Yeah, you know,
we just asked just to be
a little patient with us.
We too have been affected by Coronavirus.
Our customer service agents
have had to find new ways
to work from home.
So things may not be happening
as quickly as we would like,
but we are working on it.
And just work with us.
We're not going to disappoint you.
- Yeah, and let's see if I'm
looking at the other questions
and so we've covered a lot of this.
Still more questions
about the subject tests,
what specific dates they will be offered?
I guess, I mean, you already
answered that to some degree.
- Yeah and students should go online,
the schedule is on the website.
But if the subject tests in the fall,
we'll have the normal schedule
that will resume in the fall.
The ones that we had to
reschedule from June,
as soon as we get those
rescheduled students will know,
but we're trying to get those rescheduled
by the end of this year.
- Yeah, and from Instagram,
we got this question actually,
this is a very relevant one
because we at the Khan Academy layer,
we've gotten certain questions
around this from even school districts.
This Instagram user says "I'm a junior,
"should I keep studying for the next SAT?"
And I guess there's two
things in there which is,
you know, you got four or five months
until the August test date.
And then there might be
people who are like, well,
I can do official SAT practice.
I can take practice tests but
will the SAT look different.
What would you say to folks like that?
- We should absolutely keep studying.
I think, Sal, from your results at Khan,
we see that the more hours
that a student spends studying
the better their performance on the test.
So absolutely keep studying whether
or not you know we have the
paper and pencil and once again,
worst case scenario, we
have to do an at-home SAT.
If you studying,
you will be prepared for whatever
form of SAT gets administered this fall.
- And I'll just double down on that.
You know, what I've been
telling a lot of parents
and teachers and students,
especially students who are
high school age right now
is one of the best things, people say
how should I use Khan Academy?
And on Khan Academy we
have a lot of subjects,
going all the way to fairly advanced math
and science and all that.
But I've told high school students,
and as early as ninth graders,
if there's one thing that you know,
if you just even have 30 minutes a day,
40 minutes a day, try the
official SAT practice.
And it's not just so that you eventually
when you take the SAT you do well,
it's because it's actually
making you ready for college.
It's aligned to the standards,
it's aligned with the skills
that actually matter for college.
It's math, it's reading and writing,
you can get feedback on writing.
And so if over the next
five or six months,
you're able to put in 30
minutes, 40 minutes a day,
every couple of weeks, take
a full length practice test,
I guarantee you I guess
of money back guarantee,
it's all free.
So I guess I can't afford to do that.
But I will guarantee
you with our reputation
that if you're able to
put that time in you focus
on that practice that
feedback try to level yourself
up on the various skills,
we have plenty of
efficacy studies Lorraine
was just referring to that
show that that time put in really pays off
and we've seen efficacy
studies that six hours
from the between the PSAT and the SAT
is associated with 50%
greater than expected growth.
You can do way more than six hours
given the amount of time that
you might have on your hands
between now and and back to school.
So I think the official
SAT practice is a way
not just to do well in the SAT,
which I think it will help you there,
but it'll help you really thrive
when you go back to school
whether you're gonna be a junior, senior,
sophomore, or freshman.
Let's see from Mazzy
Guy on Instagram says,
"what changes will be added
"to the SAT course on Khan Academy?"
I'll take that, you know if
the SAT is still the SAT,
what we're talking about
this digital version
that we're talking about, is
only in this very particular
circumstance as Lorraine just mentioned.
It's still going to be very much aligned
with what what you would
need to prepare for.
So keep preparing.
- And practicing.
Sal, and I think about the practice,
it's just like an athlete who
don't know when their next
basketball game is, but
they're probably in their yard
or in their neighborhood
still practicing free throws.
You keep practicing because
the more you practice,
the better you're going to perform.
- Exactly, exactly.
And there's one question from Instagram,
which we've already answered,
but I wanna re-answer it
'cause I think it's
worth doubling down on.
"Are SAT score going to count for anything
"for next year college applications?"
Lorraine, you wanna take a stab at it
and I'm happy to answer it again.
- So yeah, yeah.
So once again, colleges are being flexible
because they too understand
that there are some students
who are applying this fall
who won't have the
opportunity to take the test.
So they're taking into
account these situations,
but students should always
reach out to the college.
If you can take the SAT,
you should absolutely take
the SAT because once again,
with the portfolio that
you have in addition
to your high school grade point average,
your extracurricular activities,
and whatever volunteer activities
that you're submitting,
SAT scores will help
colleges show the skills.
Some students and unfortunately,
Sal, when students
sometimes hear that a
school is test optional
or SAT optional, they feel oh,
I don't have to take the test.
And sometimes the more privileged students
still take it, still submit those scores.
And it's more of the underserved students
who don't have a counselor
coaching them to say,
go ahead, take the SAT regardless,
even if it's test optional,
take it and submit it.
So we really encourage you.
If you can take it,
please take it because it will do nothing
but help your portfolio and
show a better presentation
of yourself to that
college admissions officer.
- And I'll just add to that,
it's absolutely true that
everyone is more understanding
and flexible right now,
especially as we go into next
year's college admissions.
But I know that a lot
of school districts have
had to do things like go to
pass fail on their letter grades
in this in this current semester
because of the school closures.
And so that gives even less
information for colleges
to make their admissions decisions
and so that you can imagine,
it might if you can,
if you're in a position
to do so it's it might
be even more valuable
to provide those signals
of your your college readiness.
And testing, I've talked to
college admissions officers
of some fairly selective schools
that went testing optional,
but what they'll tell you is that still
a disproportionate number
of the kids who get in
did take the SAT
because they still need to look
at that they need some form of a signal.
If you don't have something
like an SAT score,
you're still going to have to
have some other kind of signal
to the college around
your college readiness
and how it actually might
compare relative to other folks.
So high;y, highly recommend
that if you're in a position
to do so, highly recommend
to keep preparing.
So we're pretty much out of time.
Lorraine, thank you so much
for answering those questions
and stay safe and healthy and glad to hear
that the College Board
folks are trying to do
what they can to support
folks through this process.
- Thanks Sal, thanks for having me here.
- So thank you, everyone,
for joining today's live stream.
We're always grateful to have guests
from some of our partners
to answer some of these questions.
I know a lot of folks are
feeling a lot of stress now.
The whole point of this live
stream is to try to de-stress
some of that.
And hopefully the takeaway
to get from Lorraine
or from all of the guests
that we're having is we're
at a moment in the world
where everyone realizes what's important
or starting to realize what's important.
And so, I would just emphasize, for folks
to do what you can.
Put the next foot forward.
Don't stress about it and
things are going to sort out.
So with that, I will let you go
and I look forward to seeing all of y'all
on the live stream tomorrow.